[Music]
good evening everyone hope you had a
great weekend
welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight I'm
Brian Kilmeade I'll be filling in for
Tucker unless I misread the schedule
from Berkeley to Portland and Tifa
demonstrators got violent over the
weekend again we've got the video you're
looking at some of it now we'll have
more of that in just a moment but first
it isn't just an Tifa that's losing its
mind in every respect
you got liberal officeholders and
candidates they're moving fast to the
left Democratic senator Brian Schatz for
example of Hawaii he's publicly
announced his support for New York Times
writer Sara Jang in a racist anti white
anti-cop tweets in Arizona gubernatorial
candidate David Garcia wants voters to
imagine a world where anybody can enter
freely from Mexico I want to just take a
second and imagine let's just imagine
just imagine no wall no wall in southern
Arizona can you imagine that nightmare
in New York gubernatorial in New York
gubernatorial candidate Cynthia Nixon
yes she's legitimately running still
says it's time for the Democratic Party
to overtly push socialism and others on
the Left seem on board the establishment
is terrified of that word socialism but
if we learned one thing from the Obama
years it's that Republicans are going to
call us socialists no matter what we do
so we find a smile give them the real
thing I think this is going this is
going to be though a debate a big debate
point on that Democratic primary stage
in 2020 isn't it I don't even think it's
going to be a debate point either
embrace the label and own it and be a
player or you can be like Andrew come on
be off in the sidelines you believe this
it's like the Republican Party is
getting the gift that keeps on giving
Nixon's New York Democratic colleague
attorney general candidate Zephyr
Teachout that's our actual name wants to
prosecute ice ice has to be abolished
and I say that as somebody who's running
for one of the top law enforcement jobs
in the country and as Attorney General I
will continue to speak out against ice I
will prosecute ice for their criminal
acts I'm embarrassed for her and
conservative lawmakers officeholders and
ordinary Trump supporters continue to
face harassment from those heeding the
call of congresswoman Maxine Waters
remember
[Music]
[Applause]
columnist mark Stein here mark there are
times when there's there you have to
really split hairs to find out where the
problem is we don't have to split hairs
here where do you start first off
socialism but just embrace it right
right you know you know 20 years ago
during the Clinton era when you watch
campaign ads the Democrats all ran as
pseudo conservatives that um Fred Smith
I'm tough on crime
I believe in there and and you had to
wait to the end to find out whether this
was a Republican or a Democrat
pretending to be tough on crime and all
the rest of it and I can understand
that's frustrating and they want to let
their inner leftist out and if you look
at the last election cycle one of the
problems with the Democrat Party is that
moderate Democrats centrism got
associated with the Clinton kleptocracy
Hillary is just someone whose turn it
was and was running a phony baloney
foundation that some kind of racket
forgetting like seven-figure sums from
Leigh about Saudi princes for doing
nothing and that tainted centrism and
all the romance on the Democratic Party
you saw with Cynthia Nixon all the
romance is on the far left and they're
moving farther and farther left at an
extraordinary rate well you have their
twenty eight year olds who upset Joe
Crowley right now she's the rock star
without any legitimate substance so she
feel lives in fear of the follow-up
question yeah any topic but you but you
see that's like the Oh I think I can
remember it's Lenin or Stalin who famous
line who whom in an age of identity
politics what matters is which side of
that you are are you the approved
designated group as that young lady is
or in the ice dispute for example the
reason they don't like ice is because
ice detains illegal immigrants I don't
particularly like the immigrant if you
anyone who's been through legal
immigration isn't fond of the
immigration bureaucracy but for the
Democrats it's simple they like illegal
immigrants so therefore the people on
the other side of that question the
immigration enforces are the bad guys so
there's a lot
law enforcement officials and families
if you don't have one directly in your
family you have one related you might
even be a good friend of yours when you
say abolish ice that hits home
everywhere yeah in what country is that
a good political thing to do and some
Democrats I think are worried about the
abolish ice move and I'll add something
to that nine out of every ten arrests
through ice are people with criminal
records what's your problem with that
well the reason the leftists came on
that is because they don't care about
that just so you know you listen to that
guy who's running for governor in
Arizona and he's saying imagine a world
where anybody can enter from Mexico
there's a name for that world it's
Mexico if you let anybody enter from
Mexico you become Mexico the border
moves north and eventually it's at the
Canadian border and you're all Mexico
I thought the debate was between the
fence the drones or the solid state wall
the debate is now for open for all in no
because again that's like the old school
Democrats use yes of course I believe in
a border enforcement once we have the
amnesty and we legalize these
hard-working people who just want and it
gets frustrating to have to do that so
it's much easier to let your inner open
borders side out their open borders
their identity politics they've had it
with the whole Clinton thing of
pretending to be
they don't want sister soldier moments
any any of that anymore they don't want
to triangulate they don't want all the
equivocations there I think they add a
certain level they actually feel dirty
from living with those accommodations
and they'd mud that last time around
Bernie Sanders by n if it had been a
free nominating process would have won
because that's where the party is thirty
one trillion dollars from Medicare for
all you had this this woman from from
New York who's going to get the seat
that Joe Crowley had come out and say
we're going to essentially get rid of
the seven hundred billion dollars to
give to the military in order to fan
that out and pay for all her social
programs no that's the fascinating thing
because if you look at genuinely
socialist countries so the average
European social democracy and
Scandinavia or whatever they pay for
their socialism what you have here is
actually a fantasy socialism where they
think none of these trillion dollar sums
mean anything so let's just give even
more and more trillions to everybody
mark Stein I'll be filling in for Tucker
on Wednesday until then mark I'll see
you in the halls I'll say hello but
it'll never be the same okay let's build
that fence and keep you at bay very much
so he's turned on me already